i'm at the brea improv right now in
california come see the babes um we got
i'm in san francisco uh september 8th to
the 10th at the uh cobbs comedy club
that's going to be fun for fun then we
got madison wisconsin milwaukee
wisconsin chicago and minneapolis all at
chrisdcomedy.com and who knows the uk
might be on sale soon christy comedy.com
ooh uk uk i think it might be on sale
right now we're not sure that's crazy
talk okay all my fall dates are up we're
starting again in october there's a
couple dozen dates up i'm going to
florida i'm going to california i'm
going to canada i'm going to evansville
indiana louisville and everywhere in
between second shows in hershey
pennsylvania atlanta georgia and toronto
right now everything's on sale at salvo
county comedy.com
san jose where my family's from i'm
visiting you in december i'd like for
you guys to come out
really i really appreciate it you got
one of your cousins lost a lot of weight
out there
savilecanoecomedy.com my nephew that
guy's great kid he lost a hundred pounds
but
nephew's second cousin removed or a
nephew no my straight-up nephew god and
he does jiu-jitsu he's ripped yeah come
see me on tour
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say it i'm everyday baby
it's all in me
[Applause]
you just called me running late it came
up as gail fine dance who's gayle yes
gail is my mom family plan we were on a
family plan and i took it over and so i
paid but she didn't change the name
so now i'm gail fighter i love it i love
that you you came in here with on your
mother's phone planned with an oversized
baseball hat you look like a make-a-wish
yes
i look like a child sinking into this
gap with the balloons behind you you
look like
cakes
give me a nickel
i thought i put the hat on so i don't
look as wet but
i love the hug
is it upside down philly yes it is for
my favorite band blacklisted they're uh
a hardcore punk band from phillies so
the b for blacklisted
philadelphia i love that philly i love
it yeah i love it dude yeah um um you uh
you're a great comic you love skay music
right is it called scar sorry you
knew that i don't
you knew it was scar ska yes or as kids
in the hood call it nah
band that you think you know anyone even
if it's broad okay any strawberry i
think i know yeah
okay
um ska band would be a ska band would be
um uh
let's see
nirvana no you are out of control
you're doing this on first i swear
never mind get out oh my gosh i swear to
god where'd you lose your mind
let's say homeless pimp
[Laughter]
dude just write me
homeless pimp who knows every uh who's a
music music aficionado goes to every rap
concert knows everything about every
piece of music can you name one ska band
uh real big fish yes yes was it that
hard sell out you know that one right
yes
no
i want my girlfriend to be my girlfriend
yeah yeah i think you're gay that's
disgusting i'm not gay
you somebody went to a breakup yup talk
about it get wet
i feel like i want you to change my
diaper
dude i'm good at that let me do it
please i could change diapers last night
i was walking a half hour i'm sweating
no well i learned the hard way that you
don't that the the safest way to do it
is front to back my daughter can take
back to front because she's a champion
what is this i was oh it's my sweat rag
you're in the bl no the crips all right
louie anderson when i was teaching in
brownsville i brought this out to like
dab my head and the kids are like mr
finance you have to throw that out
the the crips i had a red bandana they
were like the cribs
what did you teach i was a full-time sub
and then i taught tesla full-time sub
yeah
but now i'm a full-time dog
you're listed online as both depending
on what website you're on yes yeah if
it's a resume website you're a full-time
sub and if it's anything else you're a
full-time job yes it all depends on
which day you catch me on grindr any um
would you spell
g-r-i-n-d-r if you're looking at home
yes um do you okay there's no e no e no
no way okay no way um do you when you
were teaching do you have any like any
any students because this because i will
say a substitute teacher usually is like
that's kids want to make fun of a sub
substitute teacher they don't respect
you i was the coolest they respected me
i would play apocalyptico on the oh i
love the screen what a great movie yeah
it was amazing you you didn't teach i
did i went to school for teaching got a
bachelor of science in english education
not using it anymore sure i would love
if i was a student i mean if i was just
finance finance if i was a student
financial district high school i like it
that's really one of the segments on my
new podcast the financial district yeah
yeah yeah we it's it's where we offer
advice to people i like you because
you're in the financial i like it
you should have a segment called the
financial district and then a segment
called subbing with ian where you just
talk about what it is to be a bottom
line
i just wear a diaper and a harness dress
like that yeah yeah i love tmz oh tmz
yeah it's good what's tmz tmz is where i
just uh come up to my friends on a cell
phone and i go tmz in here chris to
stefano how does it feel to be italian
but also
yeah
um any any s so there was never one
student whoever was like oh
man like the class tough yeah
do you so you didn't come in and like be
like your teacher's out we're gonna
watch you know fried green tomatoes well
the school i i was a full-time sub at
was um
uh the school i student taught at so i
was on a track
to i student taught and then they hired
me as a full-time sub so the kids
already knew me okay and then teachers
were leaving and i was just going to get
a job
like teaching but i was also drinking
heavily at the time so i drank my way
out of that job
because i would uh yeah you have some
pretty wild stories when you used to
like used to be a full-blown alcoholic
and now you're now you're completely
sober which is always over
heavy drugs
unbelievable i'm raw dog in life oh i
love it dude yes and i'm getting monkey
yeah you're getting money right now
you're just like you just
oh i am off the dick i am i it's been uh
over over
over a year and a half no dick by the
grace of god relapsed at any time you
know you could do it yeah i mean what
what's wrong
dude eat the monkey box is spraying like
wildfire i know that's the sole reason
no and also it is getting there i don't
want to get in i don't want to do that
that was like my belly phase yeah you
know you all had one well you came all
the way back a lot of guys don't make it
back don't come back from gay but you
you kind of when women go cross gay come
back all the time but a lot of guys once
they go gay they stay yeah and also as a
bisexual man i feel i have a
responsibility to not be
gay guys right now and women i
appreciate because that's a way that
monkey pucks can spread yeah yes so i'm
here i could break up consciousness no i
like that i like that yeah monkey pox
actually you know we've made fun of it a
lot um for good reason because it's the
stupidest name of any disease ever and i
know that the media did that on purpose
that you can't call disease monkey pox
and expect people to take it seriously
wasn't that already around monkey pox
yeah but it's such a dumb name i mean
you can't do that how did it start
i don't know how it started but it is
hilarious
though if the flare-up is massive
lesions all over your body and it leaves
scarring it goes inside your anus and
your penile arrangement okay you can get
it from touch
like literally at these circuit parties
where men are just naked in harnesses if
you dance on someone
and sweat contact you can get it but why
the outbreak all of a sudden does anyone
know i don't know why
i have a theory what's the theory the
theory is that uh you can basically live
with hiv and aids and not transmit you
could be positive undetectable and have
such a low viral load that you're not
spreading it so because of that nobody's
using condoms in the gay community so
uh a lot i mean for a while like a new
strain of syphilis was running around
like a hardcore goddamn franklin
syphilis we got a new syphilis new
civilization
al capone syphilis nice this ain't your
daddy's syphilis wow very very
interesting this was an update this is
an update this is a new syphilis which
is good that we're progressing uh i
don't know if it's like a mutation or i
don't know how it started but i will say
if you see vaccine centers for monkey
pox the line looks like the hottest
nightclub
looks like it looks like you're trying
to get into an ian fine dance comedy
show
short shorts
it's incredible
incredible attitude
yeah yeah um that's well that's been
subbing with ian um i uh that that was
that i i think that you know you you
still have to question though at some
point where it's like now we got
back-to-back panties yeah potential
coming in do you think this is gonna be
a pandy u.s u.s today uh this episode
will be on two weeks the usa today
declared in a national health emergency
yeah the only two times they've ever
declared national health emergencies
have been covered and now this yeah wow
and now this from john oliver
so i think that i think that listen guys
i think you know for now let's just plug
it up let's plug it up a little bit and
by the way monkey pox is not a disease
that's only exclusive to the gay
community it's just right now running
rampant predominantly predominantly
that's like saying code was only
a an asian thing it's like no i'm
kidding well yeah that community was
like effective at first and then it
spread this is
focusing on the gay community if they if
you had to guess because they you know
everybody always says even it's not you
know it's just common knowledge everyone
always says that it started in cove it
started wuhan where do you think monkey
park started if you had to guess
where would you go would you go san fran
would you go west village oh probably
like uh those two places yeah yeah well
chelsea
are gay cities yeah um well listen but
our gay our gates uh city our gay
neighborhood is i think it can go up
against any gay neighborhood we the
united states chelsea boys united states
let me tell you that's a cool gang name
chelsea
we have the best gays to change the
world the chelsea handlers the chelsea
handlers absolutely i like it i like
versus sandwiches
yeah the joe coy boys
like easter sunday they'll come again
um
and if other countries want to say that
they have the best case then of course
email heybaypod gmail.com tag us at
heybaypod because i think the united
states has the top well i think we have
level 10 gays what do you think of the
european gays the european guests can't
tell the difference between gay or
european
right like if you go to italy every man
in italy looks like a u.s gay right just
every man because they're wearing capris
and they're putting them through a
european filter they're all
yeah a european man is it looks like a
us gay you cannot distinguish um where i
think that you're going to find where i
think you're going to be like wow that's
a surprise gay is if you go to the
middle east and you start to see gay
people out with their those are surprise
gays those are fearless gays
oh what tough what do you mean fearless
oh fearless
fearless meaning you have to you you're
not they don't run around
uh out do they i think at certain places
they do i think in beirut lebanon you
can be out and about i heard that the
government spies on grindr and hookup
apps and they pretend to be
gay men and then when they meet up they
arrest them and beat them after they
blow them yeah yeah that's funny like i
[Laughter]
you have to tell
me um
i uh yeah i think um you know and and
speaking of i know like this is a little
topical but i still think it'll be in
the news you know brittany grineer
yesterday nine years in prison and
they're saying in what russia nine years
she was sentenced yesterday but are we
doing a trade for one of their arms in
russia i don't know if it's gonna happen
so what they're saying is and again this
is coming out in two weeks so i don't
know what could have transpired you know
give them yakov spurn off yeah yeah yeah
that's the only way what did the akko
samira say when he lost his virginity
what what a [__]
this has been
tmz
it's one of the first kids
really wait why
it's there it's right there for the
taking
isn't it you ready for this well you
know his catchphrase what is it oh that
makes no sense to anybody his main
catchphrase is water country oh
and you don't know the number one thing
associated with him is that's his name i
don't know
do you know who knockoff smeared off his
you don't know who yaakov smirnoff is i
don't know i swear to god i do not who
is the author michael blackson of
russians yeah he's a he's a russian
comedian that got famous in the united
states very famous in movies and
everything and in commercials for like
can you pull him up have i seen him oh
no wonder you didn't buy one why would
you guys even think would know what that
joke meant
are you confident
no no no no i don't know who this guy is
i've never seen this guy i've never seen
this guy once in my life look at his
teeth and now he's famous for branson
missouri he like took over that's right
yeah what are you talking about he took
over he makes money out in branson
missouri which is like uh like vegas
right missouri yeah for like the near
dead what do you mean
makes money doing comedy
he i think he owns a casino
look
look put thai vineyard spinning over
google again and see what it said the
first thing down
[Laughter]
what a country there it is what a
country meme
yeah yeah so now that you know his
catchphrase is what the country
don't you think that what a [__] is
isn't that good incredible thank you now
that i have context i think it's one of
the best jokes we've had on the show yes
um and i think you need to bring it back
i love that you guys are like yeah yeah
yeah
well here's the thing with this britney
granny
is they're saying that they don't know
like russia's not giving russia the
thing is with russians is they don't
care about their arms they want to get a
big russian arms dealer we would give
them a russian arms dealer who's
nicknamed dr death and we would get back
britney greiner and the russians are
like keep dr death we don't give a [__]
about him no so they don't care about
russia what they're saying now is you
know what it's crazy i would get one of
their ball players well i was watching i
was i know we got to get one of their
ball players who are we going to get who
are we going to get who do we get that
[__] with them let's pull up the russian
female basketball team please yeah
ovechkin we get alexander ovechkin one
of the best hockey players we get his
ass okay and we keep him in the u.s
detention center
oh maria sharapova i'll take her the
amount of weeds she got caught i smoked
this morning how much was it a little
bit i think it's 25 vape cartridges
why didn't you bring that no i think
it's 25. are you not aware of how it was
in her bag from she travels all the time
and it was like in a bag by the pocket
she didn't it sucks it definitely sucks
but then you there's a lot of debate you
got to be like well what about all the
people in wheat and in the u.s and and
then russia because russia's just saying
hey listen this is by the book we have
to arrest her but it's like excessive
they definitely targeted her because
she's in conservative russia a six nine
lesbian yeah that's a problem in russia
to begin with yeah just talking about
gays that she what there was a uh an
american who was held in captivity in
the same prison grineers and then they
were saying that she's not going to be
treated well because she's six nine six
nine she's one of the best nba wnba
players like
right now or six ten actually so she's a
lesbian it's not going to be good for
her in in russian prison no there's no
way we don't get her back now
but i thought you're going to get
through this that's a new action movie
we sneak into russia to break around
who's going to get who do we need to get
grineer out of that russian prison who's
the only man for the job woman for the
job seagal maybe seagal stallone van
damme the gal's on their side remember
oh that's right
on it yeah no doesn't uh roy jones jr
have to go do it now
why he he he's friends with putin or
something like that am i mixing this up
oh dennis rod no dennis rodman's friends
with the guy from north korea who's
friends with pootie i i swear to god i
think roy jones jr was supposed to
yeah yeah roy jones roy jones jr what
not roy would you i thought
you'll never take roy
uh wow this is very interesting this
sucks because this woman is in the prime
of her career nine years which some
people say uh that even in the nine
years she's never going to get out
because russians will find a way to keep
you oh come on we have to do something
terrible and we got to get around yeah
but i think we're at going to probably
be at war with them soon we've given a
lot of weapons to ukraine so i think
this is bad time ukraine doesn't like
gay people either no no but i'm saying i
think as a point russia is going to say
we're not helping you with anything in
the united states unless you release the
sanctions they'll be like we'll give you
greiner if you release the world
sanctions and the u.s is not going to do
that right but also it's it's so insane
to me that there's no discretion of like
you get caught with something and they
can't be like okay just throw it out and
get on they you know like yeah did they
think she was going to deal it like no
they didn't doesn't she no they worked
out they knew they they they don't care
they they uh the russians are you know
this is why when people talk about when
people [__] on america you gotta
understand you're in the freest place
you can be in the human population is
right here in this country you can't get
more free than this and as george carlin
said in 1993 you have no rights so stop
with the my rights [__] you and your
rights that's what carlin said so if you
just understand that this is as free as
we're going to be as human population is
in this country you understand i mean if
this was in the united states brittany
grineer would be out of prison in uh uh
she would have never showed you when i
went to prison she'd get a ticket yeah
you know like nope nope and probably not
not even that which by the way i want to
say uh um whatever town in upstate new
york that pulled me over uh that officer
you could suck my ass what happened i
was going 81 and a 65. oh call me crazy
16 miles i think i honestly think it's
17 and over when you get into a little
trump truck 16 miles 16. 81 and a 65 and
this guy which is
150 bucks plus points if i if i want to
fight the points i got to go up five
hours oh no no you get yourself a lawyer
they do that
you hire a traffic lawyer okay they're
there my body's a good lawyer who's been
trafficked yeah no they i did it here i
did it in brooklyn like they have like a
guy you got pulled over
yeah
i feel like you're not a guy who would
uh it's it's very hard for me to believe
you get pulled over i got pulled over
did he recognize you his nickname is
speed limit cell
[Laughter]
cannon two volcano
uh yeah no no i've been pulled over
plenty of times i i i they recognize you
for the most part but at this time they
didn't and uh and i was looking at i lit
truly actually gatto called me while i
was driving on the belt and i picked it
up and i was like oh it's it's gatto and
i was like hey i'm driving i'll call you
back and they caught you with a cell
phone in it this is recent no it's eight
eight years i postponed it for eight
years are you serious
well they did i i you're allowed to
postpone it twice and every time i
postponed it because you know you do
that that's the strategy yeah so what
you do is you hire a lawyer that works
at that in that area you can look them
up i look them up like the freaking
phone book and you pay him you pay him a
retainer and when your date comes he
shows up for you and what they say is if
you have a lawyer present usually what
happens is you'll pay the fine you'll
lose the points but that's what you
don't want it's the point yeah i don't i
don't want the points so the first
things first before you get to the left
watch i can't have the points what's
that i'm on weight watchers you can't do
that
so so what you do is you hire him but
the first thing you do is you postpone
they let you postpone one year each time
your only answer was pulled in two years
i postponed the two years they postponed
four times after that
the city the city post one for four
years after that on the seventh year my
court date happened i sent a lawyer the
cop didn't show up with seven years
later
you have to pay the finance bill how
much do you have to pay the lawyer
though 250. you gotta send your lawyer
to brittany
yeah i mean that's what has to happen
postponed shorter than she's gonna get
in jail literally the only thing i can
save britney spears is sal's traffic
lawyer from hamilton new york that's the
only thing but he was talking about
britney granite now oh britney green i
thought you said britney spears well
you're trying to save both of them
actually yeah
because if you say britney if you just
say save br if you just give me a one
word brittany i'm only thinking of the
crazy spree yeah of course okay
grineer britney grineer brittany g
brittany murphy britney murphy oh
god wrestlers i know she i will tell you
i think there was suspicion surrounding
her death are you ready for whom my
three biggest crushes of all time were
were and slash r i'll never be ready but
go ahead okay i'm gonna tell you i'm
ready
tell me well you know that brittany tell
me what you wanna do give you all my
time i wanna make it good for you
cause you blow my mind i promise boy
that i'll be true
you're the perfect font so tell me if
you want me to remember who sang that
groove theory proof theory
um i remember how did you know that
because i remember having a walkman with
a cassette tape taking an eighth grade
eighth grade class trip listening to
groove theory tell me
i was listening dancing in the back by
myself i swear to god in the back of the
yellow cheese bus coming back from
something we did an eighth grade class
trip uh my teacher at the time sister
earl mary god rest her soul shout out to
sarah
christopher what are you listening to
and i gave her the headphones because
she she didn't you know you're not
supposed to listen to music or maybe she
thought it was offensive she got taken
by the melody she literally put it on
and was looking at me and then all of a
sudden started going like this
i swear to god she's up there she's up
there dancing right now oh [__] yeah
shout out to sister earl great lady
shout out sister earl god bless mr
o'mara she would go old school detention
if you messed up like let's say i was
talking in class to you know michael
cefudo i would have to write on the
chalkboard i will not talk to michael
sofuto a hundred times i will not talk
to michael sofia i will not say she hit
you
no we the only person that hit me is a
brother in archbishop morgan let's just
african americans right i apologize
hey
yeah you're right we're very we're
politically correct here um so so uh um
i think his name was brother art brother
art we of course call him brother fart
but brother
apostrophe
the only thing that he did is i fell
asleep and this is a move he would do i
fell asleep and you know head on the
desk like that and he would got two uh
erasers chocolate races loading up a
chart i remember hit me on the shoulder
bang breathed in the chalk cough now i
mean you cannot do that no
my third grade teacher mrs gagliard uh
threw a threw a eraser at me from her
desk and [__] pegged me right in the
[__] face pegged me get on the edge i
was shocked i i didn't see it coming
blind side of me powder went everywhere
i turned i looked at her and i could
tell
that she knew she'd done [__] up she
wasn't trying to hit a child in the face
with the elastic because even back then
that's a little bit grounds for like oh
do are we gonna call the cops yeah like
what are you doing you hit a child what
about hitting the desk
if she would hit the desk yeah like with
like the thing yeah although like
slamming down yeah to make the dust fly
with the desk
i think that that's that's peripheral i
think that's okay i had a baseball coach
once his son his son this is baseball
practice was playing second base and he
was not and
they would ask whoever was playing
catcher at the time hey he would say to
him if anyone's not paying attention let
me know because i was whole thing you
have to be like on your toes and he said
oh i forgot his son's name was david
he's like oh dave it's not paying
attention and this coach turned around
with the baseball he fully grown man and
threw the ball as hard as he could not
his son's head it was like a [__]
cartoon i swear to god his son
bent down because i'm not making stuff a
butterfly was flying under the dirt and
his son went to go cup the butterfly and
the ball missed his head by that much or
even my father who was crazy and would
call me slurds if i if i struck out was
like
don't [__] do that again
he was like you do that again you're
gonna have to deal with me
and i was like wow insane that's insane
i mean he would have killed his son in
the name of little league baseball shout
out to rgmv oh my god yeah that is
insane that he was that gay to bend over
to pick up a butterfly
he's now an escobar
watch that was cool it's on my pinky
ring oh my gosh
is it really do you skank yes yeah yeah
yes do you know what that is
do you skank yeah i know the legion of
for scott yo i made a non-music
video short for skank no
is like the sound that the guitar made
on the upbeats okay back in like uh
jamaica can we play a little scott
cartoon the specials right yeah one of
my favorites i've seen it no this is not
don't this is going to give him a bad
image give me give me the best band
what are they the big giant peaches we
can't listen to any music
nobody you might know uh the mighty boss
mighty mighty boy that's who i actually
was gonna guess but i couldn't remember
their name that's great because they had
one song they were one of the biggest
crossover sky i think yes
mighty boss stones i can accurately say
yeah there it is
they were incredible
as was brittany murphy bringing it back
scott brings people together
brittany murphy was in the mighty mighty
boss stones no idiot she wasn't clueless
the mighty might he was in the poster
oh i remember that yes the boss tones
silver bullet with kevin bacon that's
what it is yeah let me tell you
something
let me get back to my crushes three
three you ready for this number one
brittany murphy yes number two gwen
stefani scott
scott
look at their first album that oh my god
mike park from asia man records was in a
band called skanking pickle no doubt
used to open for skanking pickle as did
blink 182 and then my third crush also
falls along with the scott lisa left eye
lopez
[Music]
nice rip
those are my three questions three yours
are going to be all over you're just
gonna be a couple of genders my three
idris album no i'm kidding um now a word
from our sponsor better help there it is
baby do you take care of your mind babe
i don't always and i think it's very
important too and that's why we always
talk about this every week because you
need to take a time out and you need to
get that mental break literally what i
love about better help
is that i can
get an appointment in 48 hours because
it's all online it's all done online you
can do it with the comfort of your home
you could do it butt naked you can have
the camera off the counselors are all
certified they're all great and it
literally i don't want to go to an
office anymore i'm not trying to do that
i like it online
absolutely and if people people
there's a there there was and is still a
stigma around therapy yeah and if you've
ever been thinking it's like going to
the gym for your mind and if you've ever
been thinking about it but you were
afraid to do it or hesitant to do it
this is the easiest way to get your foot
in the door yeah because it's online uh
therapy they do video they do phone they
do live chat therapy sessions and
you also don't have to turn your camera
on which i like so if you feel a little
bit hesitant that's the way to do it and
listen the babes are going to get 10
off the first month at betterhelp.com
hey babe that's betterh-e-l-p-com
slash hey babe we have a friend who was
on the podcast who's going through a
really bad breakup we sent it we sent it
to we sent him to betterhelp.com slash
hey got 10 off and he walked himself all
the way back now he started a scar band
and he's really doing great and he
carries a knife on him at all times okay
hey ian fidenz here at ianimal69 on
instagram check out my brand new podcast
b and ian with jordan patreon.com
b e and pod the episode that comes out
tomorrow i'll tell you
me tommy pope chris o'connor and that's
right lenny dykstra you gotta check it
out nails nails came to my apartment in
my studio and hung out for two and a
half hours and then we ate chicken
sandwiches up the street hello
fresh
america's number one meal kid
i love it super every last second of
summer with hello
fresh
delivers fresh quality produce from the
farm to your dog kick in the farm within
your 4-4 all your hearts hello
less than a week
farm to your door in less than a week
allowing you to enjoy the delicious
flavors of the season right at home
skipped a grocery store one more time
soaking up the summer sun it's a
one-stop shop for all your meal time
needs with a curated selection of quick
breakfasts lunches snacks desserts and
more yummy yummy in my tummy hello
freshest quick and easy recipes 20
minute meals low prep low cleanup
options provide an even faster route to
putting food on the table and in your
mouth around your pack schedule i love
hello fresh and now enjoy more variety
than ever with hellofresh with hello
custom okay swap out one protein for
another how about that upgrade for a
more luxe experience if you want oh even
add a protein to a veggie meal and then
they go over there hello fresh 72
hellofresh is 72 percent cheaper than
dining at a restaurant and it's even
cheaper than grocery shopping that's
money back in your pocket we use it all
the time we loves it we do it saves us
time it made me an amateur cook which i
never was no you really do cook well and
again we talk about this weekly with
hellofresh we don't know how this
company makes money because they give
away so much stuff for free if you just
use the promo code listen to this go to
hellofresh.com slash hey babe 16 and use
the code hey babe 16. they're going to
give you 16 free meals across seven
boxes and three free gifts i mean well
what's the who's who does this nobody's
santa claus nobody around their
operation even one of the person who
does it
hellofresh dot com slash hey babe 16 use
code hey babe 16 for 16 free meals
across seven boxes and three free gifts
hello fresh america's number one meal
kit
oh i love you so by the way he's the one
i'm sending rescue brittany right here
oh dude he's the new james bond he's the
new best yeah the best i feel like he
could talk me into anything yeah i
didn't mean that in a sexual way either
i mean like i feel like he could talk me
into selling like like doesn't he he
did you know when you first saw him that
he was had an english voice no because
the first time he saw him wasn't the
wire
not avon barksdale
stringer stringer
he was great in molly's game
which is the poker game which chastain
yep that was a great film yeah
true story
yeah true story my top three crushes
rihanna
cindy crawford oh yeah and
um
give us a guy
who's who's oh i used to have a thing
for rupaul
okay yeah i like that gorgeous guy yeah
what about you sal can you give them
three top off the top so three like
three like in my lifetime that i had
like for a while like it was like real
legitimate
crawford was one of them yeah she was
one of them for sure crush to me means
like i genuinely fantasized multiple
times about each of these three women
like walking
not even that wasn't even sexual with
them it was like walking in the park
holding each other like things like that
all right so cindy crawford was was the
ultimate when i was younger another one
even slightly before her if we're going
like crush age
uh alyssa milano oh the best come on
who's the boss yeah who's the boss the
wall i told you this before the wall in
my room i used to buy those teen
magazines yeah and i used to take a a
exacto knife and i used to slice out the
eight by ten and i had one wall that was
wallpaper of alyssa milano there must
have been three hundred and twenty five
seconds of her ready for this oh i swear
to christ can [__] you can ask my family
where i used to live on uh i won't say
the street just case i still live there
i was just there in my apartment yes you
are in my apartment complex where i used
to live [__] little apartment
complex in bay ridge
me
jazz the kids are we didn't have violet
yet are sitting outside all of a sudden
alyssa milano come on
i swear to god walks out of one of the
apartments on the second floor
i screwed up i said where's tony danza
no but i screamed up and i said i i i
said to jazz i said is that alyssa
milano and her of course being jazz she
goes yeah did you hook up with her i
said no
i will i said that's sal's dream um um
she her cousin she's tellable there's a
chance there's a chance
her cousins lived above me for four
years no no way we moved out like a
month later but in that month i was like
i need to try to become bffs with that
she's full-blown like mentally ill now
she's a lunatic yeah she was getting out
of the garbage and she really had no
idea she was yelling landlines are
racist landlord you stole the lands from
the landline she's screaming and she's
running down the stairs
can i tell you a sleeper crush
a sleeper crush oh yeah let's do it type
it in pimpy amanda pete
oh i love my man to pete saving
silverman so hot when she spills the
sauce on yeah
what about the other one her first one
that she was in amanda pizza best and i
think she's the same last name as pete's
coffee i think they're related no i
swear to god i think amanda pete and
pete's coffee are one in the same oh i'd
like to drink you in the morning big
time crush susan sarandon and um who was
jamie lee curtis yes
in trading places
jamie lee
who was that butt model from maxim
the bump oh vera oh
no herrera viewer guerrero viraguerrero
vita vita vida vita guerrera
yes she was like in like the rap videos
and stuff like that you're typing
her she she was the s the yeah there was
usurped jennifer lopez
look at look what he put viva guerigo
what
veda is before pimp's time this is
before pimp's time there it is there she
is yeah sh if there was only fans was
around now uh she would be you couldn't
touch her you're also spelling her name
wrong because there's no way it's peter
i think it's guerra yeah there we go but
she's in red it's the one in the red
garrett garaguera g-u
g-u
no no guerrero go go back to guerrero
okay
g-u-e-r-r-a try that that sounds right
try that no no row
images wow 625 can instagram i expected
more now
oh god top right i love you yeah
that's about that oh is that her real
boobs is that her real blood
no oh
i thought she was just a model like more
bikini yes that's not her real that's
not her real see i don't like when this
happens now there's a new there's a
there's a sex tape i don't you know what
i mean i don't like it but i know what
i'm doing this evening
let's fast forward to this evening
everybody pretend you're back home
no i wow that's something even sweating
again
[Laughter]
she used to be i i guess people just i
don't know she was the maxim girl no
magazines oh
after i had them for an hour i could
never open them again oh dude i used to
get those and they the whole premise of
them was like here's a hot women and how
much they all suck cars i remember i
bought it i used my mom's credit card
and i ordered playboy one sable the wwf
yeah i was waiting for it and came today
sable is the undertaker's wife or in
real life or um or or uh no no it's no
it's um this was the one
i think brock lesnar's wife is penthouse
was cool because sometimes you could see
dicks
nice i mean sable's hot
no penthouse you couldn't but you
couldn't hustler oh yeah
you saw that dude
i remember my mom i got the sable
magazine yep she's married to a brock
lesnar whoa dude dude his finishing move
was my favorite the f5 yeah that was six
yeah yeah what is i oh yeah he like
spins you and then like almost love it
yeah um
uh sable my mom found my boy and then
she also found my porn which was we
called the blue porn it was a spanish it
was a spa colombian speaking but it was
a vhs and it was all the vhs was blue
and we would pass it around back in
these days you have to pass around the
porn yeah so i i i i was keeping the
porn for whatever it was
keeping the point and then literally my
i came home one day and my mother
had the sable magazine opened no she
didn't i swear to god the disabled
magazine opened to her boobs and then
she had found the blue porn and she had
taken a hammer and smashed it up into
like 20 times that's amazing and there
was a post-it note taped to the table
because she had went out if she had went
out with her boyfriend so god knows what
the hell she was doing right but i was
just a child gary the mall santa yeah uh
no this uh she [__] them all santa i
don't know i swear to god christmas
gamer
that's what it is
yeah christmas came on yeah
so but she had mashed it up and there
was a little post-it note and it said
get this filth and it had underlined out
of my house wow wow crazy that she
opened it up to the boobs when she could
have just stuck it to the corner yeah
and then literally my boys were like you
[__] like because you gotta you lost
the porn and like it was the thing i
actually called my dad i was like how do
i get back in with the friend group and
my dad was like there's no way yeah like
you just you lost the pulse i told you
the story about my v do you know what
vhs stands for we just looked it up
before uh uh vpr you know vcr you know
right what video vcr is what video
conferencing recording room video
um
that's what it is
really yeah why would you think it's
video home system it doesn't make sense
listen listen to me
is it vhs the vcr itself is a video
cassette recording why is the tape
of vhs the tape is called the video home
system makes no sense think about it one
vcr cartridge is a vhs cartridge it's a
vhs cartridge it's called a video home
system
the tape itself doesn't make any videos
that you put in your home system
yeah but shouldn't the vhs then be the
vcr that's the video home system the
video cassette record is the tape the vc
the tape should be called the vcr and
the vcr should be called the vhs tell me
now tell me no just like george carlin
why do people park in driveways and
drive on parkways it's the same argument
as vhs and vcr it is what it is yeah
did you re-watch carlin again
i listened to the whole way home thank
you carlin i love george carlin i love
it yeah i love it
um what the hell is this coal miners
where were we
i don't know what just happened i want
to know homeless pimp's goddamn
questions because i feel like he's
probably asexual he's our michael
jackson dude the way he's going to take
it he'd probably be like anyone that
played at lilith fair
cheryl
chapman any different
homeless pig banging tracy
that's my only fan
[Laughter]
i don't know definitely rihanna i like
rihanna oh yeah i like dualipa oh
and if i met a trans rihanna i'd give it
all up for her i think remember
jerry
tt jerry is trans rihanna no
what no tt jerry's great but i'm talking
she's not trans rupaul's clothes
rihanna yeah close the closest yeah okay
in and of that he's bla she's he's he's
black yeah right he's he's he's just he
just dresses yeah but he doesn't have
boobs
rue paul doesn't no titty does do you
remember nia long she was oh i love neil
gorgeous
nia long is beautiful
and megan good is beautiful too megan
good meg the stallion that's i like new
ones i bet you make the stallions on
pimp's crush babe
yeah but she's she's a lot to handle who
are you
oh my god she's gorgeous she's gorgeous
i do beyonce okay beyonce'd be great
childhood
no no no one of the care bears yeah i
don't know dude
i can't even think of them anybody from
it's like let's see from 40 year old
virgil he's like what the boots feel
ms-dos was hot he only knows anime
characters
he's like dragon ball z
um neo long is
definitely
there's a girl now i always forget her
name
a woman that is an actor she's very
popular she was in what's that vampire
show kate beckett sail no
vampire slayer no um oh i know
lies no no no no no no no no true um
blood true blood she was in no no she
wasn't that she was in masters of sex
hayek yes salma hayek is [__]
blasphemy that was a sexual awakening in
desperado yes oh my god she's so hot in
desperado
this girl's she was in party down she's
in masters of sex
she's she's in a lot of stuff she was in
she was in the movie called
the night before it was a show
it's a show about johnson and johnson
what
she said
the vaccine yeah that's that's her right
there the middle right down the middle
girl right there down oh she's jane
lynch
oh the girl to the top she was in mean
girls
lizzie kaplan lizzie kaplan and she's
funny she's yeah she's she's so she's
have you met her in person no i haven't
but like as always she's great she was
so good in mean girls oh lizzie kaplan's
the best and lizzy cat she's been in a
bunch of things listening
[__] jesse eisenberg oh they're just
doing a movie together i like him
you don't like him
you don't like him you don't like jesse
eisenberg yeah but i mean today like if
the woman in my dreams with jessie
eisenberg i'm like come on dude i'll
throw you out the [__] well you know
who she used to date i think
i think you know who she used to date
long term z's
i think who
chan labing
no chandler so
matthew perry yeah ccc you just saw him
go back
you know who lizzie kaplan kind of looks
like our good friend who we know kate
wolfe yeah kate wolfe shout out kate
wolf
lizzy kaplan look alike
hungry like
wolf hungry like oh now she's with him
oh yeah he's fine bets are off now what
is that crystal lions right around the
waist wing that's nice
that's hemsworth no
no no who is that we sound
[Laughter]
ghostbusters sorry i think i think his
name is chris something i think it's
chris wine chris that's that's chris
pine that's chris
i heard the name marsden morriston
marsden
oh he's a bachelorette oh come
way that was in 2014. okay so let's see
who she's up to now
let's see who she's up to now time riley
oh you can't compete with a guy who's
born in england she's engaged to this
guy from the uk to this bloke well why
don't you [__] show up to my shows in
october [__]
i'm sure there's okay in october it's on
sale soon he's gonna beat you up and
then give her my email yeah yeah
go [__] it it should be on sale in two
weeks or i'm firing my agent and i'm
going back to sal's agent
[Laughter]
um
lizzie kaplan okay top well lizzie
kaplan if you're listening and we know
that you are i know just know that the
three of us are uh we would love to be
on the lizzie kaplan fan club right here
yeah lizzy kaplan fan club lizzie
roberts
i'll take your last name kristy kaplan
no we're the lesbians that's right
yes i like it yes i like it okay the
lesbians don't call lesbians stone cold
lesbians um
i uh yeah so elon musk uh is saying that
the government made him take random drug
tests after going viral for smoking on
joe rogan show how can the government
make you take granted how is he involved
you're not involved in the government
well he has government contracts uh okay
so then that you know listen again this
is as free is it gonna be as it's gonna
be in this country yeah i know a person
for a long time he's a good friend he is
very good he's very tech savvy very very
and he works for the government
contracted by the government and cannot
tell me what he does
interesting
he cannot like legally because you know
why because
listen and he probably won't because i
bet you he believes truly in his heart
or it might even be happening they have
a listening device somewhere on him
where he cannot say anything no i guess
what if you guys went to the beach could
he tell you in the water
that's a good question
if you wanted a hot air balloon we've
been in my car
and you couldn't tell but hasn't been on
the beach in the water you go to the
beach in the water and you record it
make them dunk get under and then come
up and tell me it's a good strategy do
it
yeah but he's like i can't talk about it
he's gonna talk about the beach in the
water yeah you know anybody in the in
like the fbi or the cia i know a guy in
the fbi i know two fbi's you ready for
this i know a guy in the fbi and the guy
in the fbi is the one who told me who's
uh is my friend's father is the one who
told my friend who told me that
grineer's never getting out of prison if
he knows anything about the russians
which allegedly he was worked in moscow
for a long time allegedly
he knows he said that they will keep
finding things to do
with the and she will never get out of
prison as long as the u.s and russia are
still fighting i hope that he is wrong
for for me for our sake yeah speaking of
the allegedly look at this let's shout
it out get out no no we got a bit that
we do on the show where we go allegedly
and a fan made this but it's so cool is
it a sticker it is yeah but it moves
moves can i have this yes i have online
oh no
i need one i need one at least i love
this
i need one take one okay well then he
took us
all right okay v he took us here sorry v
no you got it it's yours on my podcast i
have a refrigerator with all stickers of
things i like i love it right in the
middle oh i love it yeah so guys check
this out so let's let's shout out
uh
lauren nation is that her real name
lauren nation
i like rhythm nation like the rhythm
name yeah lauren nation ren nation
originals hey babes i hope you like
these my husband and i love the show as
well as taste buds and chrissy chaos i'm
an artist and my husband wanted a
sticker like this so i made them i think
the design turned out pretty cool let me
know what you all think if you'd like to
collab we would like to collab 100 i
love this i would love to do more with
you and i would love to get this to our
fans yes this is a genius idea you and
your husband are geniuses it's carried
out perfectly this is my favorite
sticker it's just unbelievable that's
what it is thank you so much someone
will be reaching out to you let's make
it we sell it you guys get one eight
percent of the profits we go home yeah
we're not gonna get saratoga peanut
butter also shout out saratoga peanut
butter shout out to her and i forgot
that she wrote to us to do a re-up of a
new flavor after i blanked
and i feel bad because we want we want
to do that with her and i don't know i
sarah we have our own i'm telling you
this right now
no listen to me can i taste it yes get
this on t get this on tmz i love peanut
butter no saratoga peanut butter is the
best peanut butter i've ever had in my
life
hundred thousand percent i still have
the no pressure pack look up at that's
the hay baby peanut butter taste buds
the other podcast what is it
yo peanut.com the saratoga peanut butter
hey babe and taste buds flavors are
amazing but go search any flavor you
want it is truly the best peanut butter
i've ever had correct why not charity
that's so good and all the proceeds go
to charities i'm going to get portions
she gets hers and then yeah yeah i love
peanut butter i know we're going to make
a new flavor you maybe you could help us
out if you haven't oh my gosh what's the
new flavor what if you had any peanut
butter flavor what would you uh
why would your peanut butter flavor the
ones that we had were white chocolate
almond butter with dried blueberries and
butterscotch peanut butter so what would
you do oh my god i would oh you don't
even know bro
caramel raspberry peanut butter what
whoa wow
what
might drop all my nuts
you see what happens the
venatia what peanut butter would venatia
dill vanity is greek should be like a
feta cheese peanut butter with oil
butter i know we asked venetia her three
she's like zeus
zeus john themos and a coffee cup and a
coffee cup um ballin
once they're selling two thousand dollar
trash bags
kill ghost scratch balenciaga go suck an
egg yeah don't get monkey pox enough
enough enough disrespectful balenciaga
one thousand seven hundred ninety dollar
uh trash bag
is it a fashion trash bag or do they
want you to put like is it a bag it's
gonna be a bag got it that's just made
like a trash bag yeah ironic i guess
yeah interesting and kids are buying
this off the shelves yeah i've been
doing that for years it's called hefty
okay
and it's got a little scent in it so my
clothes don't yeah yeah yeah yeah does
balenciaga have a cinch sack yeah
i've done that many times this is this
is making fashion out of homeless
people's luggage
literally zoolander daryl leaked right
right it is just oh it's so insulting
look at this headline china announces
sanctions against nancy pelosi following
taiwan visit hahaha
[Laughter]
no more importing pelosi's no more
exporting grineers that's what it is
i like it um that's funny she's gotta be
uh do you know her i hope she gets
released asap her first game back oh my
god she's gonna dunk on something she's
gonna just murder people we have to be a
british first game basically they should
let her they should let her just just
smoke the pen while she's playing yeah
just after she dreams at three she's
like
yeah
oh i would love it what if what if
she's in russia and she
loves it and they try to release her and
she goes no i want to stay like what if
she fell in love with like somebody in
russia do you want to rush
becomes a part of it start runs like the
russian gang and she's like the go-to in
the russian prison because she's the
tallest she's the strongest how about
she's like what if they flip her she
comes back as a spy
interesting whoa very very interesting
britney grenier is the russian spy ver
watch homeland that's what they did
homeland what if they're like hey you
become a spy and we'll give you special
treatment you can play basketball you
could be the captain of the girls
basketball team in russian prison
which usually we hold tryouts for it
it's tough
that'd be insane what if what if
what if the the the u.s just says or
russia just says listen
give we'll give you brittany greiner
back but you got to give us jeffrey
epstein because we know he ain't dead
uh-huh what if they do that and putin
wants epstein personally no i i i asked
alan dershowitz about epstein you asked
that you had alan dershowitz on your
podcast no no no no i
i went on the anthony kumi show and i
didn't know dershowitz was going to be
on they had them phone by the way these
socks can you put up your feet for a
second look at the front the tops of
these socks i always look they always
look like a hair net to me
yeah like they're just cut
my nose shows the front goes here and it
looks like i'm wearing like uh it looks
like i'm wearing balance if you just put
the foot up ian has a woman's foot i
have a ballet foot you do have a ballet
foot
that's disgusting
well ian bikes all over the city
ian's ian is even though he smokes two
packs a day is one of the problem i
would argue cardiovascular physically
fit comics we have in our personal scene
yeah yeah who's
i mean sergio sergio is the other guy
sure he smoked two packs of red today
yeah he doesn't give a [__] and you
don't care no you don't care at all and
that's you're going to do that yeah
why packing after two he's from philly
but why delaware
you're not worried about
how old are you now 37. you're not
worried about the future and your
trachea and all that i'm living for
today okay and you're never gonna stop
no i love that i built a studio on my
basement i got a air purifier
uh a window that opens [__] ripping
butts it's amazing
i smoke on the bike you chain smoke yeah
so when's the last time you had a
cigarette today right before you came in
right before i came in i'm [__]
jonesing you want one bad if we said it
was okay it's not but if we said it's
okay to smoke cigarettes you'd light one
up right now he would go crazy what's
the longest you ever went with that one
yeah
how long did you make talking to mike
talking about
pandemic i went three weeks i was losing
my mind i love that you were like you
know what i'm gonna stop smoking when
there's a virus out that will attack my
lungs at least
my lungs will still get hit hard that i
thought if i'm sorry i don't want to
damage my lungs i'll damn i'll die
because of the smoking and then i
thought why am i not doing the one thing
i need to do to
feel good but why are you thinking about
just maybe is it everything maybe i'm
glib i love reds i love how hard they
are i do i was doing marlboro lights
too light i can't feel them can i
interest you in livestream.com
he said i'm bi i ain't gay dude i i just
love the act of smoking of hitting a
pack it is cool i used to smoke i smoked
for a decade smoked for a decade and
then i quit for six years and i smoked
for years again wow yeah this lighter
cover oh it's really nice when's the
last time you smoked a cigarette sal um
like bought a pack when like like when
was the last time i smoked before i quit
smoking or when's it when is the last
time you had a cigarette in your mouth
uh probably in the last couple of years
like really drunk someone would hand me
one i take one one to two puffs tops
hand it back blow it out and say that
felt good and disgusting at the same
time that's it i'm ready ready for this
tomorrow george rhodes birthday party
i'm willing to smoke a cigarette
you can film it i don't think that you
should i'll film it
i think one if you don't smoke i think
one full cigarette will kind of mess you
up a little bit no mess me up like it'll
get me hot
you'll get guys doing it you'll get high
for sure like you'll literally get
tingly but then also you you might have
a cough
the next day i don't know alyssa milano
will [__] you
gwen stefan will lisa left eye lopez
[__] me she'll come back from the dead
didn't she die in a fire she died in a
car accident unfortunately
oh a car accident there's video footage
of you it sucks yeah it's terrible um i
say smoke but what made you start
smoking again after all that time um
yeah i think i was stressed that's the
thing i've been stressed so i smoke more
and when i'm on the road i smoke a ton
like if i'm alone yeah for sure you know
especially like driving yeah i got it
driving is great yeah blasting tunes
yeah that's why i make all my like phone
calls you know you know i i when i was a
physical therapy uh physical therapist i
don't think i was a student yeah i was a
physical therapist i um worked in a
nursing home for like two months and i
met this woman she was 99 and her family
put in a nursing home because her son
was dying that's why she had to go to
nursing home but she said she smoked
cigarettes every single day she had a
cigarette every single day multiple
cigarettes over her life since she was
11. yeah that's what my grandmother was
when i started
my grandmother you had a cigarette every
day of your life you're 11. i smoked a
couple when i was 11. stop start again
at 13
stopped at 15 and then started full-time
every day since 21.
so you have not missed a cigarette in
your body in 16 years oh the three weeks
of the pandemic yeah right and then i
quit for 50 days back in like
2015 but i was smoking weed every day
like a cigarette so you want to quit
there's a part of your brain that wants
to quit eventually yes because dying of
emphysema and everything is such a
horrific way of dying my aunt died that
way it sucks it sucks do you know how
you die with that do you know what it is
like ex-fiction you breathe
the air out you drown in your own fluid
yeah that's what happens yeah it's
terrible then you gotta do that thing i
don't well that's my feeling
yeah is that i'm going to lose my voice
and i'm going to have to be this comic
yeah your voice is your do you ever see
the key appeal with that comic oh yeah
oh did you see that
he appeals to the group did you see nope
no no no
[Music]
like insult comic i think it's called
i've lost my voice a couple times
because i like yell and run around a lot
yeah and uh it's scary yeah it is but i
lost this weird thing in the morning i
don't feel good until i have a cigarette
so i can yeah i understand it's like
your coffee yeah yeah yep that's it
you might not be able to show this but
you'll like it you'll die laughing
[Laughter]
you guys want to watch the whole scene
no we can't you know because you can't
show it right
don't cut the uh
i think we said this on the episode last
week of the week before it's the best i
personally think number one sketch show
yeah i think it's number one yeah i mean
i'm saying better than chappelle
yeah i agree with that
he he thinks they they they like kind of
he's throwing some shade their way oh
him get out
wow
he's basically like i did it i i was in
front of live studio audience i threw
the sketches i was in it's the same
exactly yeah but the sketches are better
than king appeal i mean i will tell you
i think you should leave is amazing but
they need a more bigger body of work to
get on that yeah i think yeah i think
you should leave comes out with seasons
three four that are bangers which is
probable and then they're here the heel
is shown in sketch classes as examples
do you think they're friends
do you have shows tonight
i have a 1am okay movie night movie
night i got uh penny vodka at the house
that is my favorite pasta really yeah
really amazing nice penny vodka and a
cigarette
[Music]
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate